so you got to premiere waitress and then
so many different places now we're here
in Toronto is it slightly for you to
premiere it again oh my god thousand
percent yes every opening of this show
is so exciting
and part of it is that we get to bring
this beautiful story to a new community
and people who may not have seen it
before
this show has so in so many ways just
completely changed my life so I get
personally so excited when this thing my
little baby is gonna come to a new
community so people know you from you
being a recording artist and all the
albums that you've made in the past but
how did you get involved in this I was I
had moved to New York and I was looking
for a way to get involved in theatre I
grew up doing musical theater and I was
a little burnt out I was on my I guess
my third record and touring cycle at
that point and I was just exhausted and
a little bit bored and and I love being
an artist I love playing concerts but it
is a monotonous circuit and so I was
looking to just take a break and do
something different thinking that I
would maybe be in a show for a little
while or audition for something and then
I got paired up with Diane Paulus who's
our director and this show was in its
incubation and very quickly I said yes
to what felt like an experiment and then
it very quickly took over my life and I
absolutely drank the kool-aid and became
like I moved to Boston when they were
going up to but I mean like I was hook
line and sinker involved in the show in
such a deep way so it changed everything
a lot of the touring artists I talked to
you mentioned that burnout he has a very
very real thing and yeah they all need
to do their own things to kind of take a
break yeah but you'd open to another
type of work yeah as as a breaker person
that just can't sit still and needs to
be making things all the time no I
learned that I need to be more careful
about what I say at the same time I love
sitting still to a certain extent I am a
little bit of a busybody but I love to
be able to wander in my life but
actually it was so different than the
work I was used to there was so much
play and so much joy in this process
there were times where I was like I
cannot believe this is like my job right
now is that I'm I'm sitting in theater
in Times Square or I mean I'm in a
rehearsal room and we're playing with
how do we make the pies move I mean it
was just so creative and so joyful so
much of it was yeah it was really hard
to don't don't get me wrong but I just
enjoyed it so much that it didn't feel
like work
what is it intimidating at all getting
into I mean not just writing music that
you perform yourself music that's about
you in your life or things that you're
thinking but getting into another
character and one that people might know
from having seen the film and also just
like you said being part of the entire
planning and development process yeah it
was really intimidating and I think some
of that like what I had in my corner was
my naivete I had such a little
experience in knowing what I was saying
yes to I had no idea that it was that it
would be as all-consuming as it was but
I think that was actually it was a good
thing I didn't I didn't even have time I
didn't have the awareness to be as
overwhelmed as I probably should have
been are you working on anything else
I'm like not yet but as I know what I'm
getting into for now yeah I'm gonna take
it mama needs a minute yeah I mean truly
part of the entire thing like you got to
perform on Broadway as well um were you
nervous about that oh yeah absolutely
the the first time I've done it now
three different stints which tells you
how much I loved it and the first time I
did it I was very very intimidated but I
have to say it was it was that one of
those things that just like is
calling to you forever and ever I mean I
think having a childhood background in
the theater and being on stage and being
a storyteller in that particular kind of
capacity was always really interesting
to me my family's really theatrical my
mom's an actress my sister's an actress
so it's it's in the blood in some way
but yeah it was very intimidating but I
also had the the luxury of being really
in the womb of this of this community
and not only my waitress family which is
beyond beyond like some of my closest
dearest friends and our Mike BAM on
state like these people I'd worked so
closely with they were so ready to
receive me and support but also the
theater community at large which is like
nothing else I've ever experienced it's
it's incredible yeah you guys must have
that here in Toronto alayka sure it's
the the the people who get to work and
be involved in the theater is it's a
really really magical place yeah it's
like so tighten it you make bonds that
will last forever right completely and
it's so it's ephemeral so it's it's
changing all the time and so there's a
real sense of them you bond quickly you
you you know hold tightly and let go
lightly it's it's a really beautiful
skill set I think one of those bonds
that you've made is with Andrew Lloyd
Webber which is amazing a crazy thing I
got a Christmas card yeah when you have
it I mean I can't even begin with that
like you've worked with him on Jesus
Christ Superstar and you got to perform
it and like when you think about your
child self like meeting Andrew Lloyd
Webber and yeah I mean getting Christmas
card from it I'm like how do you feel
about it I mean it's it's just one of
those things that lives in this sort of
the Surrey ality of of life where your
things just feel bizarre but at the same
time I get to just I just get the great
honor and privilege of knowing this
extraordinary talent who has impacted me
from
being a really young child and then was
I got to witness him in the room in a
creative process and how gracious and
open and creative he is still I mean
he's writing things in the moment and
you know it's it was so beautiful and
such a I just felt very honored I think
sometimes we envisioned meeting our
heroes sometimes we think about like
what we will learn from them what we can
take from them did the reality meet the
expectations that had exceed the
expectations I think yes yes it met and
exceeded them I mean I think you know
there's not that many people worried
you're still really starstruck around
them so he's definitely one of those
people where I found myself getting a
little tongue-tied but my big takeaway
is that he remains incredibly invested
in particular and he's he has really
he's not someone who like made this
thing fifty years ago and decided I
don't care about this anymore
I mean he's he cares about how this
material lives in the world and that I
thought was really meaningful because it
would be so easy to I mean he's a
bazillionaire I cares yeah and he hand
picks what goes in his theaters and he I
mean he's he's I think that's beautiful
and it shows how much it cares about
what he makes is that part of your
approach with waitress because this is I
mean this has been a project you've
worked on for years and years now yeah
and again premiered it in a lot of
different places and you're here with us
now in Toronto and do you still have
your hands I mean in the pie so to speak
absolutely yeah yeah I mean some of that
is that I'm a I'm a control freak but
also I mean truly I this sounds cheesy
but um if I didn't love this project so
much I probably wouldn't be here you
know name like I I love this show I love
it so much I believe in it I believe in
the message I believe in the people who
are telling this story every night on
stage our cast our crew our band like we
have hand-picked all of those people I'm
still in all the casting sessions I
would still review and approve everybody
who comes onto this stage and tells the
story on our behalf
were in constant communication with our
producers about the life of the show at
large and maintenance and you know it's
important to me because I put my heart
and soul in this and I want it to be
well taken care of unlike a film that
you can watch on screen and watch at
home when you're - yeah a show like this
is a living breathing thing yeah every
single night it's different and totally
different
it must have evolved a lot from the
beginning so how when you go from to the
city how does the change like how it
would be different here in Toronto
versus anywhere else well the best part
is that the audience informs the show in
such a profound way and that was like
the amazing thing that I got to learn
from being on stage is that I really
prepared myself for it feeling very
monotonous I'm like okay I'm gonna do
the same thing every single night I'm
gonna get bored because I'm Sagittarius
but I stepped on stage and I could not
believe how different it was from night
tonight so you realize the incredible
power an audience has and the impact
they have on the performers so you know
I know from being a concert giver here
that Toronto fans are extraordinary fans
that they are passionate they're loving
their generous their vocal like I think
this show will will play really well
here and in the audience's will will
help it come to life when they're really
fun things about being a member of a
performing troupe and performing for
live audiences when you're on stage the
communication that you have with each
other that the audience has no idea when
something's gone wrong and nobody knows
except you
yeah are there in jokes or signals that
you all have on stage that you everybody
knows Universal for things well all I'll
say is that this show is a props
nightmare it's like we joke about it
it's like props on props on props yeah
and Jenna the lead character is you are
touching everything every fork every not
getting every plate like she's got to
touch basically everything on stage many
times over so where the forks go in your
apron and how they land on if there's
just always things that are wonky yeah
and it's really funny to kind of watch
the cast have to juggle because
there's as predictable as you can try to
make it sometimes the pie slides off the
thing you know you just you can't you
can't it's like when trolls are
everything pies forming there was a
stretch of time that you got to have
Jason Mraz performing with you guys got
to share the stage yeah what was that
like and what did you learn from each
other in that space that you hadn't
known about each other before oh that's
a great question
I've known Jason a really long time and
some of my very closest dearest
girlfriends are in his band and his
collaborators raining Jane and so I've
known him in a different capacity and I
invited him to try this you know and as
a as a friend and as someone who had
done it for the first time as well I was
like I promise you you're gonna like
this and he said he shared with me that
he was really scared to do it and
decided to do it because he was scared
to do it and and he has since said that
it totally changed his life too but I
was so moved by Jason's generosity and
his courageousness onstage to like he
that's someone who really is comfortable
in front of an audience and comes alive
in ways where you're like oh you know
exactly what you're doing you know how
to engage and work the crowd in a
certain way no you know but not breaking
the fourth wall so you have to be in a
story with someone but also include an
observer and in an interesting way but
and singing with Jason Mraz is one of my
favorite things to do on planet I bet it
he has the most beautiful voice and it
is just so so so much fun to sing with
him